Factory is Europe's leading producer of
industrial batteries that go into
forklifts golf carts and pleasure boats
its owner sunlight has 12 factories
around the world but it's amid the
cotton fields of northern Greece that
it's planning to spend 1.6 billion
dollars on its next project to recycle
lithium a strategic metal that isn't
mined in Europe it's a key component in
batteries and in ever higher demand as
the global economy electrifies but no
one has developed a recycling process
for it yet it's not an easy place and we
have we should not pass the message that
this is an easy place to do business it
has become better in the last years
certainly we are competitive here we
could be more competitive we can be more
flexible
but still there is a lot of work to be
done and we stay here because we believe
that we can change Greece and put it in
another trajectory for us and our kids
Greece's main advantage is its Highly
Educated Workforce but nearly 10 percent
of it has left for better jobs elsewhere
during the economic crisis a decade ago
many of Greece's top companies and
employees fled
four years ago the ruling new democracy
conservatives promised to bring them
back they cut corporate tax by seven
points and brought Greek government
bonds back to the brink of investment
grade status to lower the country's
borrowing costs Greece enjoyed five and
a half percent growth last year Well
above the European average of three and
a half percent and is slated to
outperform Europe this year and next but
that tide hasn't lifted all boats
the new Democracy party tried to nurture
an economy of scale it offered tax
breaks for mergers and halved income tax
for farmers in cooperatives but
inflation has swamped the benefits
there's been a doubling or tripling of
expenses on products farmers buy while
the value of his produce has only gone
up about 50 percent our Cooperative runs
cotton mill whose electricity bill used
to be 80 000 Euros a year in the past
two years it's gone up to two hundred
thousand and three hundred thousand
respectively
small Enterprises and self-employed
people find it hard to stay in business
they say they could better weather
inflation if they weren't also battling
a bureaucratic and politicized state
their vote on Sunday will largely be a
vote to change that culture John
saropoulos Al Jazeera Xanthi
at chat GPT and other